[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur les plateformes numériques
de public sénat
j'espère que vous avez passé un bon
premier week-end de confinement et on va
commencer cette semaine en regardant ce
qu'il ya dans vos journaux régionaux
avec votre revue de presse des
territoires à la une de la provence ce
matin il est question d'un homme dont on
parle beaucoup en ce moment le
professeur didier raoult lé chef de
l'infection paul des hôpitaux de
marseille
il défend le recours immédiat à la
chloroquine pour guérir du coroner virus
une position qui lui a valu des
critiques en tout cas ce médecin publié
un livre pour mieux comprendre les
épidémies et notamment le choléra 19 le
journal la provence publie les bonnes
feuilles de ce livre le professeur il
fait preuve de pédagogie et raconte
l'histoire des différents cours navires
us le sarce de chine en 2003 le
coronavirus saoudien de 2012 et le co
vide 19 qui frappe actuellement la
planète didier rahout revient sur
l'utilisation de la chloroquine en chine
où l'épidémie a été ralenti de manière
assez rapide
le professeur l'écrit noir sur blanc
avec la chloroquine le coronavirus et
l'infection respiratoire la plus facile
à traiter au monde
alors si vous souhaitez vous faire votre
idée sur ce livre pendant ce confinement
y aller à disponible sur liseuse
numérique chez michel lafon
et puis notez dans la provence qu'il y à
ce matin un cahier spécial sur le
coronel virus expliqué aux enfants
le courrier picard vie dans ce matin sur
la mort du premier médecin hospitalier
est décédé du coronavirus on l'a appris
hier c'était un médecin urgentiste de
l'hôpital de compiègne jean-jacques
arraf un drap nazi âgé de 67 ans il
s'était occupé des premiers patients
français atteints par la maladie
notamment un agent de la base aérienne
de creil dans l'oise
son fils raconte ces deux dernières
semaines son père était rentré de
vacances de madagascar il assurer un
service sans février deux jours après il
était très fatigué il avait de la fièvre
mais il est quand même reparti
travailler une minute de silence sera
observée par les habitants de la ville
de compiègne
les médecins sont sur le pont pour
sauver des vies les militaires également
à la une de corse-matin le porte
hélicoptères tonnerre de là
marine nationale qui avec 8 hier douze
malades de l'hôpital d'ajaccio vers les
hôpitaux
marseille une opération hors norme
racontée par corse matin car c'est un
hôpital flottant qui s'est déployée hier
le navire qui contient 70 lits
actuellement a été reconfigurée pour
accueillir à delhi et hip eco vite 19
qui font plus de 50 kg huit patients en
réanimation ont été transférés quatre
patients sous assistance respiratoire
on pense un transfert très délicat et un
médecin confie au journal de corse matin
et bien c'est comme si on transportait
du cristal toujours sur l'effort
militaire pendant cette crise noté que
l'hôpital de campagne des armes est
installé à mulhouse devrait commencer à
fonctionner aujourd'hui
et puis ce soir nous saurons si la
période de confinement va être prolongée
de plusieurs semaines le conseil
scientifique va rendre son avis en
attendant des français continuent à
s'affranchir des règles c'est le cas à
nantes où une messe catholique a été
organisée dans une chapelle une messe de
la communauté st65 avec une vingtaine de
personnes et quand on parle
d'interdiction à la baie qui organisait
cette messe il estime être dans les
règles et il répond je cite je suis le
médecin des âmes
alors pour faire face à certains
irresponsables les maires durcissent les
règles et de plus en plus d'élus
instaure des couvre-feux le maire de
cholet en a décidé ainsi
premier couvre-feu du département du
maine et loire c'est à lire dans le
courrier de l'ouest
un couvre-feu de 21h à 5h du matin et
une amende de 38 euros en cas
d'infraction pour le maire gilles
bourdouleix qs le but n'est pas de
mettre des amendes mais que chacun
comprenne l'importance de se protéger et
surtout de protéger des autres les
maires sont donc en première ligne dans
cette crise et en lisant les nouvelles
on découvre ce portrait d'une mère qui
pendant le confinement et bien elle
livre le pain et les devoirs à ses
habitants cela se passe dans la commune
de landifay et berteigne mon dans le
département de l'aisne
la maire sandrine beaudoin et des
équipes municipales ont décidé d'aider
les 269 habitants du village chaque
matin le pain est livré notamment aux
personnes âgées
et puis les équipes municipales livre
également les devoirs pour les familles
ils n'ont pas d'imprimante chez elle
voilà un bel exemple de solidarité de
nos élus pendant cette crise sanitaire
c'est la fin de cette revue de presse
des territoires n'hésitez pas à
continuer à vous en vous enfermez sur
notre site publicsenat.fr vous saurez
tout sur cette crise sanitaire également
sur cette crise économique
je vous dis à demain et n'oubliez pas
rester chez vous
[Musique]